Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 6.36am on May 22, 1994, police negotiator Detective Wayne Gordon dialed through to the telephone located inside the home of Ivan Malat. The early morning call stirred Ivan from his sleep and when he picked up, Detective Gordon introduced himself and advised Ivan that his Cinnabar Street property was surrounded
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人不安的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用或我们网站上本期节目的简介。1994年5月22日上午6点36分，警方谈判专家韦恩·戈登（Wayne Gordon）警探拨通了位于伊万·马拉特（Ivan Malat）住宅内的电话。清晨的来电将伊万从睡梦中惊醒，当他接起电话时，戈登警探自我介绍，并告知伊万，他的朱砂街（Cinnabar Street）房产已被
by heavily armed officers enacting a search warrant in relation to an armed robbery. Ivan was instructed to exit the house via the front door, turn left, and then walk through the front gate with his arms raised. Dumbfounded, Ivan responded. Okie dokie, just let me put my pants on. Five minutes ticked by, but there was no sign of Ivan. Detective Gordon called the house once more and Ivan's partner, Chalinda, answered before handing the receiver over to her boyfriend.
大批武装警员包围，他们正在执行与一起持械抢劫案有关的搜查令。伊万被指令从前门走出房子，向左转，然后举起双手穿过前门。伊万一脸茫然地回答道：“好吧，好吧，让我先穿上裤子。”五分钟过去了，但不见伊万的踪影。戈登警探再次打通了这栋房子，伊万的伴侣查琳达（Chalinda）接了电话，随后将听筒交给了她的男友。
When asked why he hadn't followed orders, Ivan expressed his disbelief about the entire situation. Certain, the negotiator was one of his workmates playing a prank. Detective Gordon responded. No mate, I'm from the police, it's no joke, this is real. Still unsure, Ivan queried, why didn't you knock on the bloody door or something? Gordon informed him that it was standard police procedure to first make a call to ensure the safety of all concerned.
当被问及为什么没有按照命令办事时，伊万对整个情况感到不可思议，确信这位谈判专家只是他的一位同事在恶作剧。戈登警探回应道：“不，伙计，我是警察，这不是玩笑，这是真的。”伊万仍然心存疑虑，质问道：“你们为什么不敲该死的门或者做点别的？”戈登告知他，首先打个电话以确保所有相关人员的安全是标准的警方程序。
Ivan chuckled, still in disbelief, and told the negotiator he couldn't see anybody outside his window. Gordon once again ordered him to walk outside and turn left at the gate, but this command only amplified Ivan's doubt as he didn't have a gate on his property. Nevertheless, he announced. Alright, I'll play your little game, but I'm not real keen on this. Officers covering the inner perimeter of the premises radioed through to their command post advising they could hear movement inside the garage, including what sounded like a
伊万轻声笑了笑，仍然满腹怀疑，并告诉谈判专家他看不到窗外有任何人。戈登再次命令他走到室外并在大门处向左转，但这一命令反而加剧了伊万的疑虑，因为他的房产根本没有大门。尽管如此，他还是宣布：“好吧，我陪你们玩这个小游戏，但我实在对这不感兴趣。”负责该住宅内部警戒范围的警官通过对讲机向指挥所通报称，他们听到车库内有动静，包括听起来像是
car door opening and closing. They expressed concern that Ivan was planning an escape. By 6.48am, their suspect still hadn't emerged from the house, so Detective Gordon phoned for a third time. Chalinda answered again, saying, We are coming out now, he's just trying to find his keys. He always loses them in the morning. A few minutes later, Ivan the Lat walked out of the house with his hands up. Ivan complied with orders to get on the ground, as two heavily armed police officers placed
车门开合的声音。他们表示担心伊万正计划逃跑。到上午6点48分，他们的嫌疑人仍未从房里出来，于是戈登警探打了第三次电话。查琳达再次接听，说道：“我们这就出来了，他只是在找钥匙。他早上总是找不到钥匙。”几分钟后，伊万·马拉特举着双手走出了房子。伊万顺从了趴地上的命令，两名全副武装的警察为他
him in handcuffs. Chalinda exited the premises soon after and was escorted to a waiting police car. Detective showed Ivan a copy of their search warrant, informing him that they were making inquiries in relation to the 1990 armed robbery of English backpacker Paul Onions, adding that they would also be asking questions in relation to the seven murdered backpackers discovered in Belangelo State Forest. Ivan responded, I don't know what you're talking about. Superintendent Clive Small was overseeing the raid from the police command post.
戴上了手铐。查琳达不久后也走出了住宅，并被护送至一辆等候的警车旁。警探向伊万出示了一份搜查令副本，告知他他们正在就1990年英国背包客保罗·奥尼尔斯（Paul Onions）遭持械抢劫一案进行调查，并补充说，他们还将就贝兰格洛国家森林（Belangelo State Forest）中发现的七名遇害背包客一案进行盘问。伊万回答道：“我不知道你们在说什么。”克莱夫·斯莫尔（Clive Small）警司正在警察指挥所监督这次突袭行动。
Once Ivan's house was cleared and it was confirmed that no one else was inside, he gave the go ahead for officers to proceed with the next step. Ivan was lifted to his feet and taken inside his home to give detectives an impromptu tour and explain the purpose of each room. He was then left in the living room under the dutiful watch of two detectives, as other officers initiated a full scale search of the property. Police were equipped with a list of over 100 items to be on the lookout for, ranging from weapons and ammunition, to the various items of clothing, jewellery and camping equipment
一旦伊万的房屋被清理完毕并确认里面没有其他人，他就下达了让警官们进行下一步行动的指令。伊万被拉起身来，带进屋内，以便带领侦探们进行了一次即兴参观并解释每个房间的用途。随后，他在两名侦探的尽职看守下被留在起居室里，而其他警官则开始对该房产进行全面搜查。警方配备了一份包含100多件搜查目标的清单，从武器和弹药，到各种衣物、珠宝和露营装备——
the seven Belangelo victims were in possession of at the time of their disappearance. As the search of Ivan's bedroom commenced, police discovered a driver's license displaying Ivan's photograph alongside his brother Michael's name and personal information. There was also a postcard written to Ivan dated just days after the disappearance of British backpackers Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark that began with the words, Hi Bill, the false name he had given to Paul Onions. An envelope in his bedside drawer contained foreign currency, including New Zealand Dollars and Indonesian Rupiah, with print dates that didn't coincide with the time Ivan was known
这七名贝兰格洛受害者在失踪时都随身携带了这些物品。随着对伊万卧室搜查的开始，警方发现了一张驾照，上面印有伊万的照片以及他弟弟迈克尔（Michael）的姓名和个人信息。还有一张写给伊万的明信片，日期就在英国背包客琼·瓦尔特斯（Joanne Walters）和卡洛琳·克拉克（Caroline Clark）失踪几天后，信以“嗨，比尔”开头——这是他给保罗·奥尼尔斯的假名。他床头柜抽屉里的一个信封里装有外币，包括新西兰元和印尼盾，其印刷日期与伊万
to be living outside of Australia. German backpacker Simone Schmidl had returned from a trip to New Zealand just before her disappearance, and German couple Gabor Nogabauer and Daniel Habschied had travelled to Australia via Indonesia. Ivan denied owning any firearms or keeping any on his property, yet a large array of ammunition was discovered throughout his house. A cupboard in Ivan's bedroom contained a tin storing 38 22 calibre bullets and an unused 12 gauge shotgun cartridge.
已知在澳大利亚境外居住的时间不符。德国背包客西蒙妮·施密德尔（Simone Schmidl）在失踪前刚从新西兰旅行回来，德国夫妇加博尔·诺加鲍尔（Gabor Nogabauer）和丹尼尔·哈布希德（Daniel Habschied）则经由印度尼西亚前往澳大利亚。伊万否认拥有任何枪支或在房产内藏有枪支，然而在他的整栋房子里却发现了大量的弹药。伊万卧室的一个橱柜里有一个铁罐，里面存放着38发.22口径子弹和一个未使用的12号霰弹枪弹壳。
Similarly, four boxes of early brand 22 calibre cartridges were uncovered in a spare bedroom, featuring the same batch number as those recovered from the area 8 location in Belangelo, near where the remains of Gabor Nogabauer and Daniel Habschied were found. All of the 22 calibre ammunition found in Ivan's home was suited for use with the Ruger and Denshoots rifles fired by the Belangelo serial killer. A plastic bag carried 32 and 45 calibre Winchester ammunition, the latter of which had copper tips, matching the bullets Paul Onions cited in his attack as revolver. The bag also contained a spent 22 Winchester cartridge with a unique upward indentation,
同样，在一间客房里发现了四盒早期（Eley）品牌的.22口径子弹，其批号与在贝兰格洛A区（发现加博尔·诺加鲍尔和丹尼尔·哈布希德遗体附近）回收的弹药批号相同。在伊万家中发现的所有.22口径弹药都适用于贝兰格洛连环杀手所使用的鲁格（Ruger）和安舒茨（Anschütz）步枪。一个塑料袋里装着32和.45口径的温彻斯特（Winchester）弹药，后者带有铜尖，这与保罗·奥尼尔斯在袭击中提到的左轮手枪子弹相符。袋子里还装有一枚用过的.22温彻斯特弹壳，上面有一个独特的向上压痕，
a marking caused by a known firing pin fault in Ruger rifles manufactured between 1964 and 1982. The exact same indentation was present on cartridges recovered from two of the Belangelo crime scenes. Ivan's bedroom drawer also held a receipt for a pump action shotgun purchased from a gun shop in the western Sydney suburb of Horsley Park. During a search of the laundry, an officer's attention was drawn to the washing machine, where he noticed the substantial gap between the base of the appliance and the floor underneath. He got down on the floor and discovered a 32 browning pistol which appeared to have been
这种标记是由1964年至1962年间制造的鲁格步枪中已知的击针故障造成的。在从贝兰格洛的两个犯罪现场回收的弹壳上也存在完全相同的压痕。伊万的卧室抽屉里还放着一张从悉尼西部郊区霍斯利帕克（Horsley Park）的一家枪械店购买的泵动式霰弹枪的收据。在搜查洗衣房时，一名警官的注意力被洗衣机吸引了，他注意到该电器的底部与下方地板之间有相当大的缝隙。他趴在地板上，发现了一支.32勃朗宁手枪，这把手枪似乎是
split under the washing machine in a hurry. The firing enquiries would reveal the pistol had been stolen during a break in at the office of the Rhodes and Traffic Authority near Campbelltown in August 1977. A cupboard in Ivan's hallway contained a pair of his work boots, one of which had a Ruger rifle receiver stuffed inside. The receiver is the frame of the firearm that houses the internal components such as the firing mechanism and the bolt. In addition, there was a map of the southern Highlands region, including the Belangelo
匆忙中被塞到了洗衣机底下。弹道调查显示，这把手枪是在1977年8月坎贝尔敦（Campbelltown）附近罗兹和交通管理局（Rhodes and Traffic Authority）办公室的一次入室盗窃中被盗的。伊万过道的一个橱柜里装着一双他的工作靴，其中一只靴子里面塞了一个鲁格步枪机匣。机匣是枪械容纳击发机构和枪机等内部组件的框架。此外，还有一张南高地（Southern Highlands）地区的地图，包括贝兰格洛
State Forest, plus maps of Newcastle and Wollongong. When asked if he had ever been to Belangelo, Ivan claimed to have only ever bypassed the forest down a dirt track during the mid-80s. In response to whether he owned a Ruger firearm, Ivan said, I've told you before, I don't own any weapons. The group of attending police officers conducted the most thorough search possible, ensuring nothing in the house went untouched. By the time they were through, numerous items of interest had been recovered, including
国家森林，以及纽卡斯尔（Newcastle）和卧龙岗（Wollongong）的地图。当被问及是否去过贝兰格洛时，伊万声称只在8年中期顺着一条泥路绕过该森林。对于是否拥有一把鲁格枪支的问题，伊万说：“我以前告诉过你们，我没有任何武器。”参与行动的警察小组进行了最彻底的搜查，确保房子里的任何东西都没有被放过。等到他们搜完时，已经找到了大量引起兴趣的物品，包括
a foot-long buoy knife, three magazines about shooting, a homemade silencer, multiple rolls of black electrical tape, cable ties, telescopic sights, a camouflage-coloured paintball mask, and a police radio scanner with Ivan Malat's name engraved on it. The electrical tape and cable ties matched those used to construct a leash-restraint device that had been found at one Belangelo crime scene. Police also found an Olympus brand Trip S model 35mm camera, which was only available for sale in the United Kingdom, and matched the camera-owned by English backpacker Caroline Clarke.
一把一英尺长的布伊刀、三本关于射击的杂志、一个自制消音器、多卷黑色电工胶带、扎带、望远瞄准镜、一个迷彩颜色的彩弹面具，以及一个刻有伊万·马拉特名字的警方无线电扫描仪。电工胶带和扎带与在一个贝兰格洛犯罪现场发现的用于制造皮带约束装置的材料相吻合。警方还发现了一台奥林匹斯（Olympus）牌Trip S型号35毫米相机，该相机仅在英国有售，与英国背包客卡洛琳·克拉克拥有的相机相符。
Stuffed inside a garbage bag in Ivan's sister Shirley's bedroom, police found a green and purple Salewa brand sleeping bag identified as belonging to German backpacker Simone Schmidel. In addition to the sleeping bag, a Markill brand cooking set and cups found in the kitchen pantry were confirmed to be the same type carried by Simone, as was a carrying pouch and green water bottle found in a cardboard box. A search of the garage revealed more items of camping equipment similar to those owned by Simone, including a multi-coloured Arno strap and a blue Salewa sleeping bag cover. The cover contained a green Vowde brand Hogan model 10, tied with a compactor-map band.
在伊万的妹妹雪莉（Shirley）卧室的一个垃圾袋里，警方发现了一个绿紫相间的萨莱瓦（Salewa）牌睡袋，经辨认为德国背包客西蒙妮·施密德尔所有。除了睡袋外，厨房储藏室里发现的马基尔（Markill）牌厨具和杯子也被证实是西蒙妮携带的同款，在一个纸箱里发现的携行袋和绿色水壶也是如此。对车库的搜索发现了更多类似于西蒙妮拥有的露营装备，包括一条多色阿尔诺（Arno）背带和一个蓝色的萨莱瓦睡袋套。睡袋套里有一个绿色的瓦德（Vaude）牌霍根（Hogan）10型号帐篷，用垃圾压缩袋的束带捆扎着。
The same as the one found tied around Simone's head upon the discovery of her remains. The second green and beige sleeping bag was identified as the one Australian backpacker Deborah Everest had borrowed from her brother before her trip to Sydney in 1989. Police also found a striped green pillowcase with five lengths of sash cord inside, one of which appeared to be stained with blood. A red Holden Jackaroo four-wheel drive was parked in Ivan's garage, though he claimed he had owned a car for the past six years and that the vehicle belonged to one of his brothers.
这与在发现西蒙妮遗体时绑在她头上的带子完全相同。第二个绿米相间的睡袋被确认为澳大利亚背包客黛博拉·埃弗雷特（Deborah Everest）在1989年去悉尼旅行前向她哥哥借的那个睡袋。警方还发现了一个带有绿色条纹的枕套，里面有五段饰带，其中一段似乎沾有血迹。伊万的车库里停着一辆红色的霍顿杰卡鲁（Holden Jackaroo）四轮驱动汽车，尽管他声称自己过去六年一直拥有一辆车，而这辆车属于他的兄弟之一。
Inside the vehicle was a British 20 pence coin with a print date of 1989. Perhaps the most bizarre of all was a sticker on the back of the vehicle which promoted a crime prevention service crime stoppers with its motto reading, Put the Finger on Crime. A manhole was used to access the roof cavity of Ivan's home, where police found some Christmas decorations and other boxes containing miscellaneous items. But upon removing some sheets of insulation, they were able to peer down into the wall cavities where they spotted a plastic bag resting behind the living room wall. A stick was used to try to reach the bag, but in doing so, it caused something to dislodge
车内有一枚铸造日期为1989年的英国20便士硬币。也许最奇怪的是车后面贴着的一个贴纸，上面宣传的是犯罪预防服务机构“灭罪热线”（Crime Stoppers），其座右铭是“把手按在犯罪上”（Put the Finger on Crime）。检修孔被用来进入伊万家中的屋顶夹层，警方在那里找到了一些圣诞装饰品和其他装有杂物的盒子。但当移开一些绝缘板时，他们得以窥视墙壁夹层，在那里他们发现了一个靠在起居室墙壁后面的塑料袋。他们用一根棍子试图够到这个袋子，但在这样做的过程中，导致某样东西被震落，
and fall further down into the space. A hole was cut through the wall to retrieve the item, which was revealed to be a 10 shot Ruger rifle magazine. Inside the plastic bag itself, police found parts of a .22 caliber Ruger rifle, a trigger assembly and a breech bolt assembly. When presented to Ivan, he denied ever seeing the firearm parts before, saying that nobody had ever been in the sealing space except for quote, you blokes and the builders. Ivan Malat was taken to Campbelltown police station for further questioning, where it
并进一步落入了空间深处。墙上被凿开了一个洞以取回该物品，经查明，这是一个10发装的鲁格步枪弹匣。在塑料袋内部，警方发现了.22口径鲁格步枪的零件、扳机组件和枪机组件。当把这些展示给伊万时，他否认以前见过这些枪械零件，并称除了“你们这帮家伙和建筑工人”之外，从来没有人去过那个天花板空间。伊万·马拉特被带到坎贝尔敦警察局接受进一步审讯，在那里，
became apparent to interviewing detectives that their suspect was intentionally playing dumb. Ivan claimed to be hard of hearing and that he didn't understand their questions. When asked to corroborate the record of conversation that took place between himself and the detectives during the raid, Ivan refused, saying, we never had a conversation. He claimed not to know where any of the camping equipment found in his house came from, suggesting police may have planted the items there. In relation to the blangalow murders, Ivan said, I don't know anything about them.
负责审讯的侦探们发现，他们的嫌疑人是在故意装傻。伊万自称耳背，听不懂他们的问题。当被要求证实突袭期间他与侦探之间进行的谈话记录时，伊万拒绝了，并说：“我们从来没有过谈话。”他声称不知道在他家中发现的任何露营装备是从哪里来的，并暗示警方可能是把这些物品栽赃在那里的。关于贝兰格洛谋杀案，伊万说：“我不知道它们是怎么回事。”
I haven't got a clue. As Superintendent Small observed the interview from another room, he got the impression Ivan was enjoying himself and knew exactly what was going on, appearing confident he would soon be going home. According to the book Fate by Neil Mercer, a former colleague of Ivan's explained, quote, Ivan said to me once, if you ever get into trouble, I'll give you a solicitor that can get you off a murder rap. This bloke is the best.
“我一点线索也没有。”正如斯莫尔警司在另一个房间观察审讯时所感觉到的那样，他觉得伊万玩得很开心，并且对发生的事情心知肚明，显得确信自己很快就能回家。根据尼尔·默瑟（Neil Mercer）所著的《命运》（Fate）一书，伊万的一位前同事解释说：“伊万曾经对我说过：‘如果你遇到麻烦，我给你推荐一个能帮你在谋杀罪名上脱身的律师。这家伙是最好的。’”
You just have to deny it. If you're prepared to take a hiding, just deny it, because they have to come up with the proof. Just flatly deny it and ring for solicitor John Marsden. Following Ivan's arrest, his sister Shirley did exactly that, contacting the lawyer who would help her brother get off his rape and armed robbery charges back in the 70s. John Marsden arrived at the police station soon after and informed his client not to speak a word.
“你只要否认就行了。如果你准备挨顿打，那就直接否认，因为他们必须拿出证据。坚决否认，然后给律师约翰·马斯登（John Marsden）打电话。”伊万被捕后，他的妹妹雪莉照做了，联系了这位曾帮她哥哥在70年代洗脱强奸和武装抢劫指控的律师。约翰·马斯登不久后抵达警察局，并告知他的当事人一言不发。
While the raids were taking place at Ivan's property, police simultaneously closed in on several other members of the Malat family. They arrived to the small rural Southern Highlands township of Hilltop, located 40 kilometers north of Belanglo, to conduct a raid of the property belonging to Ivan's brother, 42-year-old Walter Malat, better known as Wally. The split-level brick dwelling was surrounded by scrub and featured a secure underground workshop. More than 40 boxes of evidence were collected from Wally's residence, including a paintball
在对伊万的房产进行突袭的同时，警方也同时包围了马拉特家族的其他几名成员。他们抵达了位于贝兰格洛以北40公里的南高地小型乡村小镇山顶（Hilltop），对伊万的弟弟、42岁的沃尔特·马拉特（Walter Malat，人称沃利Wally）的房产进行了突袭。这栋分层砖砌住宅被灌木丛环绕，并设有安全的地下作坊。从沃利的住所收集了40多箱证据，其中包括一把刻有首字母I.M.的彩弹
gun engraved with the initials I am, and a blue-colored high Sierra brand day pack matching the one carried by Simone Schmidle. This was in addition to Simone's larger backpack, which had been handed to police the day prior by Alex Malat and his wife Joan. A total of 24 weapons were seized, including an Anschutz 22-caliber rifle modified to fit a silencer, numerous other firearms, two machetes, two bayonets, and a hunting knife. A quarter tonne of ammunition found on site included six boxes of Winchester brand winner model 22-caliber bullets and 12 boxes of yearly brand ammunition that featured the same batch
枪，以及一个蓝色高山（High Sierra）品牌的日常背包，这与西蒙妮·施密德尔背的背包相符。除此之外，还有西蒙妮较大的背包，该背包是由亚历克斯·马拉特（Alex Malat）和他的妻子琼（Joan）在前一天交还给警方的。警方共查获了24件武器，包括一把改装以安装消音器的安舒茨.22口径步枪、众多其他枪支、两把大砍刀、两把刺刀和一把猎刀。在现场发现的四分之一吨弹药包括六盒温彻斯特牌赢家型号.22口径子弹和12盒早期牌弹药，其批号
numbers as the discarded boxes of ammo recovered at Belanglo's Area A crime scene. The bolt of the Anschutz rifle and several other firearms and packets of ammunition were found inside a yellow haversack marked with Ivan's name. In addition, 500 grams of marijuana was also uncovered, resulting in Wally Malat being charged with firearm and drug offences. This also descended on the property of 38-year-old Richard, the Malat brother who allegedly told co-workers that there were more bodies in the forest, including those of German citizens prior to the discovery of Simone, Gabor, and Danya.
与在贝兰格洛A区犯罪现场回收的废弃弹药箱的批号相同。安舒茨步枪的枪栓以及其他几支枪支和一包包弹药是在一个标有伊万名字的黄色帆布包内被发现的。此外，还查获了500克大麻，导致沃利·马拉特被控枪支和毒品罪。警方还突击搜查了38岁的理查德（Richard）的房产，据称这名马拉特兄弟在发现西蒙妮、加博尔和达尼亚之前，曾对同事说森林里还有更多尸体，其中包括德国公民的尸体。
Richard also lived in the southern Highlands town of Hilltop, just one kilometer away from Wally, residing on a one-and-a-half-aco rural property which contained two caravans with an adjoining annex, two aluminium sheds, and two vehicles. As the search commenced, including a dig of the surrounding dense bushland, Richard was asked about the contents of two wooden cupboards stored in his garden shed. He said they held nothing of interest, just some electrical equipment and nuts and bolts. Police instead found a large amount of camping equipment, including a blue and lilac Carabin brand sleeping bag, a blue and orange ultimate brand sleeping bag, and a caramat brand sleeping
理查德也住在南高地的山顶镇，距离沃利仅一公里，居住在一处占地一个半英亩的乡村房产上，该房产包含两辆带相邻附属建筑的大篷车、两个铝制棚屋和两辆车。搜查开始后，包括对周围茂密灌木丛的挖掘，理查德被问及存放在他花园棚屋里的两个木柜里的物品时。他说里面没有什么有趣的东西，只是一些电气设备以及螺母和螺栓。相反，警方发现了大量的露营装备，包括一个蓝紫相间的卡宾（Carabin）牌睡袋、一个蓝橙相间的终极（Ultimate）牌睡袋，以及一个卡拉马特（Caramat）牌防潮
mat, matching items belonging to Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark. In addition, a blue three-person tent was found that featured a small hole with makeshift repairs in exactly the same location as the one that had been given to the British backpackers by their travelling companion Steve Wright. A red hairbrush with the word England on it was found in his vehicle, identified as similar to one Caroline took with her when she departed for Australia. When asked who all these items belonged to, Richard replied, I don't know. Numerous weapons and firearms were also recovered, as well as a driver's licence featuring Richard's
垫，这些都与属于琼·瓦尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克的物品相符。此外，还发现了一个蓝色三人帐篷，其上面有一个带临时修补的小洞，位置与他们的同行同伴史蒂夫·赖特（Steve Wright）送给英国背包客的那个帐篷完全相同。在他的车里发现了一把印有“英格兰”（England）字样的红色发刷，经辨认，它类似于卡洛琳前往澳大利亚时随身携带的发刷。当被问及所有这些物品属于谁时，理查德回答说：“我不知道。”还缴获了众多武器和枪支，以及一张印有理查德
image but issued under a false name, and the length of blue and yellow rope similar to that found in Belangelo near Gabor Nukabauer and Daniel Habschied's remains. Police also found marijuana on the property, subsequently charging Richard with firearm and drug offences. According to Richard and Wally, they came to be in possession of some of the firearms and ammunition seized from their properties in March 1994, when Ivan enlisted their help to store the items elsewhere out of concern that, quote, the police might come and investigate.
肖像但以假名签发的驾照，以及一段蓝黄相间的绳索，类似于在贝兰格洛加博尔·努加鲍尔和丹尼尔·哈布希德遗体附近发现的绳索。警方还在该房产上发现了大麻，随后以枪支和毒品罪起诉了理查德。据理查德和沃利称，他们在1994年3月开始拥有从他们房产中没收的一些枪支和弹药，当时伊万请求他们帮忙将这些物品存放在别处，因为担心“警察可能会来调查”。
Ivan also stated their sister Shirley was upset about the items being kept on their property and wanted them gone. Richard and Wally agreed, storing the items in an alcove at Wally's house. Margaret, the Malat family's 76-year-old matriarch, still lived at the weatherboard house in Guilford where Ivan, Richard and another of her son's David had lived during the time period the Belangelo murders had occurred. Despite her ailing health, Margaret remained as fiercely protective and defensive over her sons as ever, refusing to assist police in the search of her property.
伊万还表示，他们的妹妹雪莉对这些物品存放在他们家里感到不安，并希望它们被弄走。理查德和沃利表示同意，将这些物品存放在沃利家里的一个壁龛里。玛格丽特（Margaret），马拉特家族76岁的女家长，仍然住在吉尔福德（Guilford）的那栋木板房里，伊万、理查德和她的另一个儿子大卫在贝兰格洛谋杀案发生期间曾住在那里。尽管身体状况不佳，玛格丽特对儿子的保护和捍卫依然如故，拒绝协助警方搜查她的房产。
Inside the garage, police found a yellow shirt sold exclusively in the New Zealand City of Christchurch by fashion retailer Hallenstein Brothers that matched one of four purchased by Simone Schmidel during her travels there. Also found was a next-brand shirt that matched one English backpacker Paul Unions claimed to have left behind in Ivan's vehicle following his failed abduction. In addition, a rag torn from a men's shirt bore similarities to the strips of material that had been used to gag Joanne Walters. A metal locker inside the house was padlocked shut and Margaret refused to hand over the
在车库里，警方发现了一件黄色的衬衫，该衬衫由新西兰基督城（Christchurch）的时尚零售商豪伦斯坦兄弟（Hallenstein Brothers）独家销售，与西蒙妮·施密德尔在那里旅行期间购买的四件衬衫之一相符。还发现了一件Next品牌的衬衫，这与英国背包客保罗·奥尼尔斯声称在绑架未遂后留在伊万车里的一件衬衫相吻合。此外，一块从男式衬衫上撕下来的抹布，与用来塞住琼·瓦尔特斯的嘴的布条有相似之处。屋里的一个金属柜被挂锁锁死，玛格丽特拒绝交出
key. Police forced it open and found it contained several firearms, including a .22-caliber Slazenge Hornet rifle with Ivan's name engraved into it and two Canadian $5 bills. Elsewhere inside the house, they also seized a sword and several photographs they believed could be of assistance to the investigation. Raids were also undertaken at the Bargo residence of Ivan's brother Bill and his wife Carolyn, where two firearms belonging to their son and some books about murder and cannibalism were seized.
钥匙。警方强行撬开它，发现里面藏有几把枪支，包括一把刻有伊万名字的.22口径斯拉泽奇·黄蜂（Slazenger Hornet）步枪和两张面额5加元的加拿大纸币。在屋里的其他地方，他们还缴获了一把剑和几张他们认为对调查有帮助的照片。警方还对伊万的弟弟比尔（Bill）及其妻子卡洛琳（Carolyn）位于巴尔戈（Bargo）的住宅进行了突袭，缴获了属于他们儿子的两支枪支以及一些关于谋杀和食人的书籍。
The caravan the couple were holidaying in at Lake Tabauri was also searched, as authorities suspected the pair may have taken some of the backpacker's camping property on the trip. Yet, they found nothing deemed of key importance to the Belanglo investigation. On May 23, the day after the raid, police conducted a second formal interview with Bill and Carolyn, during which Bill produced a photo album with the Easter 1992 written on the front. The album contained images of a Malat family trip which they claimed took place during
这对夫妇在塔包里湖（Lake Tabauri）度假时所住的大篷车也遭到了搜查，因为当局怀疑两人可能在旅行中拿走了背包客的一些露营财产。然而，他们没有发现被认为对贝兰格洛调查具有关键重要性的任何东西。5月23日，即突袭的第二天，警方对比尔和卡洛琳进行了第二次正式讯问，期间比尔出示了一本相册，封面写着“1992年复活节”。这本相册包含了一次马拉特家族旅行的照片，据他们称，这次旅行发生在
the time period that Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark went missing. One photo showed Ivan alongside the vehicle he owned at the time, a silver Nissan Patrol four-wheel drive. According to Bill and Carolyn, the photos proved Ivan was away with the family when the two young women were murdered. However, it was obvious to the interviewing detectives that Easter 1992 was not the original date displayed on the album. It appeared as though the initial date had been crossed out, with the newer one written
琼·瓦尔特斯和卡洛琳·克拉克失踪的时间段内。其中一张照片显示伊万和当时他拥有的汽车——一辆银色日产途乐（Nissan Patrol）四轮驱动汽车在一起。据比尔和卡洛琳称，这些照片证明伊万在两名年轻女子被谋杀时正与家人外出。然而，负责审讯的侦探们一眼就看出，1992年复活节并不是相册上显示的原始日期。最初的日期似乎被划掉了，新日期被写在
in its place. When asked if they were attempting to create a false alibi for Ivan, Carolyn insisted she had made the change a long time ago, explaining, I wrote it wrong when doing the album. If I wanted to make up an alibi, I would have done a much better job of it. It was during further inspections of the album that police realized Carolyn had overlooked one crucial detail. The date that each photo had been taken was written on the backside of each image.
了它的上面。当被问及他们是否在试图为伊万制造不在场假证明时，卡洛琳坚称她很久以前就做过修改，并解释道：“我在做相册时写错了。如果我想伪造不在场证明，我会做得好得多。”正是在对相册的进一步检查中，警方意识到卡洛琳漏掉了一个至关细节。每张照片拍摄的日期都写在每张照片的背面。
Flipping over the photo of Ivan with his Nissan Patrol revealed someone had sprawled the words, Max Truck 1991, Mac being one of Ivan's nicknames. The vehicle had a bullbar on the front and what appeared to be white Liam's wool seat covers, just like the car used in the attack on Paul Onions. Another photo album recovered from Ivan's Eagle Vale home contained more images of his Nissan Patrol, along with photos of the accused killer as he posed on an armchair wearing a cowboy-style hat, armed with a Winchester rifle. In another photo, Ivan's girlfriend, Chalinda, stood in front of the ocean wearing a white
翻开伊万与他的日产途乐的照片，发现有人潦草地写着“麦克斯卡车1991”（Max Truck 1991），麦克斯是伊万的绰号之一。这辆车的正前方有一个防撞杠，似乎还有白色的羊毛座椅套，就像袭击保罗·奥尼尔斯时使用的汽车一样。从伊万的伊格尔韦尔（Eagle Vale）家中回收的另一本相册包含了更多他的日产途乐的照片，以及这名被指控的杀手戴着牛仔式帽子、手持温彻斯特步枪坐在扶手椅上摆姿势的照片。在另一张照片中，伊万的女友查琳达站在大海前，穿着一件白色长袖衬衫，胸前印有贝纳通（Benetton）品牌名称，这件衣物曾属于英国背包客卡洛琳·克拉克。
long-sleeved shirt with the brand name Benetton printed across the front, which was an item of clothing that had belonged to English backpacker Caroline Clark. A search warrant of Chalinda's home was issued, but the shirt was not recovered. Furthermore, a photo taken from Wally Molat's house dated March 29, 1991, showed Ivan carrying a green and beige sleeping bag, identified as the one previously carried by Australian backpacker Deborah Everest, who went missing just over a year before the photo was captured. That same day, Ivan Molat appeared in the Campbelltown local court for the first time, where he sat motionless as the formal charges against him were detailed.
警方对查琳达的住所发出了搜查令，但没有找到这件衬衫。此外，一张摄于沃尔·莫拉特（Wally Molat）家中、日期为1991年3月29日的照片显示，伊万正扛着一个绿米相间的睡袋，经辨认，这就是澳大利亚背包客黛博拉·埃弗雷特以前携带的那个睡袋，黛博拉在照片拍摄前一年多失踪。同一天，伊万·莫拉特首次在坎贝尔敦地方法院出庭，针对他的正式指控被详细宣读时，他一言不发地坐在那里。
For the attack on Paul Onions, he was charged with armed robbery, kidnapping, and using a revolver with intent to commit an indictable offence. Not entering a plea, he was represented by Jim Marsden, the brother of his long-standing lawyer John Marsden, who was unable to appear in court that day as he now held a position on the New South Wales Police Board and was attending a police association conference. Jim Marsden asserted that his client was a good candidate for bail as he had a solid work record, had resided in the same property with his sister for the past 15 months, and had maintained a clean criminal record over the past 20 years.
关于对保罗·奥尼尔斯的袭击，他被控武装抢劫、绑架，以及蓄意使用左轮手枪实施可起诉罪行。他没有进行抗辩，由吉姆·马斯登（Jim Marsden）代表出庭。吉姆是他的长期律师约翰·马斯登的弟弟，由于约翰目前在新南威尔士州警察委员会担任职务并正在出席警察协会会议，因此当天无法出庭。吉姆·马斯登坚称他的当事人是保释的良好人选，因为他有良好的工作记录，过去15个月一直与姐姐住在同一处房产中，并且在过去20年里保持着干净的犯罪记录。
Marsden justified Ivan's decision to flee the country following his 1971 criminal charges for rape and armed robbery by explaining that at the time, his client was a young man frightened by the prospect of facing trials for crimes he didn't commit. Citing the serious nature of Ivan's most recent offences, the strength of the prosecution case, and the possibility that Ivan may re-offend, the magistrate refused his request for bail. Outside the court, a gathering crowd shouted abuse, insults and death threats at Ivan as he was driven off to Long Bay Jail, where he would be held until his next scheduled court appearance eight days later.
马斯登为伊万在1971年因强奸和武装抢劫罪被指控后潜逃出国的决定进行了辩护，他解释说，当时他的当事人是一个年轻人，对面临未犯下罪行的审判前景感到恐惧。鉴于伊万最近罪行的严重性质、控方证据的强有力程度以及伊万可能再次犯罪的可能性，地方法官拒绝了他的保释请求。法院外，聚集的人群向伊万大声辱骂、侮辱并发出了死亡威胁，随后他被驱车送往朗湾监狱（Long Bay Jail），他将被关押在那里，直至八天后下一次预定的出庭。
In order to lay charges for the seven backpacker murders, Task Force air investigators had just over one week to examine all of the items recovered from the various malat properties to determine what exactly could be directly linked to the Belangelo victims and crime scenes. If they failed to gather sufficient evidence, they faced the possibility that their prime suspect in the killings would once again be released on bail. The various ruger rifle parts discovered in Ivan Malat's home presented Task Force air with the best opportunity to strengthen their case against him. In particular, the Breachbolt Assembly had the potential to leave a unique mark on spent
为了对七起背包客谋杀案提出指控，空军特别工作组（Task Force Air）的调查人员只有一周多一点的时间来检查从各个马拉特房产中回收的所有物品，以确定究竟有哪些能够直接与贝兰格洛受害者和犯罪现场联系起来。如果他们收集不到足够的证据，他们将面临谋杀案的主要嫌疑人再次被保释释放的可能性。在伊万·马拉特家中发现的各种鲁格步枪零件为空军特别工作组提供了加强对他的指控的最佳机会。特别是，枪机组件有可能在用过的
cartridge cases akin to a fingerprint. Therefore, it was paramount to determine if Ivan's Breachbolt Assembly produced the same markings found on the cartridge cases recovered from the Belangelo crime scenes. Ballistics expert Gerard Dutton inserted Ivan's Breachbolt Assembly into a ruger rifle obtained from the Ballistics Firearms Library. He then fired ten Winchester cartridges before examining the markings left behind on the casings. In an interview with True Crime television series Crimes That Shook the World, Dutton
弹壳上留下类似于指纹的独一无二的印记。因此，最重要的是确定伊万的枪机组件是否产生了与从贝兰格洛犯罪现场回收的弹壳上发现的相同的标记。弹道专家杰拉德·达顿（Gerard Dutton）将伊万的枪机组件插入从弹道枪械库获得的鲁格步枪中。随后，他发射了十发温彻斯特子弹，然后检查了弹壳上留下的标记。在接受罪案纪实电视系列剧《震惊世界的罪行》（Crimes That Shook the World）采访时，达顿
said, I felt all the hairs on the back of my neck stand up on end. It was quite an extraordinary sensation. Those individual marks which I was so familiar with on the Caroline Clark murder case, I was now seeing on my testified cases. I was quite happy that component that we recovered from the wall cavity of Malat's house was fitted to the murder gun that was used to kill Caroline Clark. The markings produced by Dutton's test also matched to those on the cartridges recovered
说道：“我感觉到后颈上的汗毛都竖起来了。那真是一种非同寻常的感觉。我在卡洛琳·克拉克谋杀案中非常熟悉的那些个体标记，现在正出现在我测试的弹壳上。我非常高兴，我们从马拉特房屋墙壁夹层中回收的那个部件，正是用于杀死卡洛琳·克拉克的凶器。”达顿测试产生的标记也与从加博尔·诺格鲍尔遗体附近的贝兰格洛A区犯罪现场回收的弹壳上的标记相匹配。
from Belangelo's Area A crime scene near Gabor Nugebauer's remains. The batch number on a Winchester brand ammunition box recovered from Area A was traceable from factory floor to store shelves and was determined to have been supplied to 55 gun shops throughout Australia in 1988 prior to the Belangelo murders. One of those stores was located in the western Sydney suburb of Horsley Park. The significance of the Horsley Park store was highlighted after a receipt for the purchase of a pump action shotgun was found during the raid of Ivan's home. In fact, Ivan was found to be a regular customer, having bought several firearms from the store
从A区回收的一箱温彻斯特品牌弹药的批号可以从工厂车间追溯到商店货架，经确定，该批弹药在1988年贝兰格洛谋杀案发生之前曾供应给澳大利亚各地的55家枪械店。其中一家商店位于悉尼西部的霍斯利帕克郊区。在突袭伊万家期间发现了一张购买泵动式霰弹枪的收据后，霍斯利帕克商店的重要性凸显了出来。事实上，伊万被发现是一名老顾客，他用假名诺曼·陈（Norman Chong）从该店购买了多支枪支。
using a fake license issued under the name Norman Chong. The serial number on the rifle receiver found in Ivan's work boot was also traced to the Horsley Park store, which came to be in possession of the Ruger rifle after its original owner pawned it to the shop in 1988. There was no record of the gun having been sold to Ivan thereafter, an error for which the store owners would later be fined. However, Ivan did visit the shop using his fake license just days before the Ruger was traded in there.
在伊万工作靴中发现的步枪机匣上的序列号也可以追溯到霍斯利帕克商店，该店是在原主人于1988年将该枪典当给该店后拥有了这把鲁格步枪的。没有记录显示此后该枪曾被卖给伊万，店主后来因这一失误而被罚款。然而，就在鲁格步枪被交易到该店的前几天，伊万确实使用他的假驾照光顾了这家店。
Ballistic tests were also carried out using Deanshut's rifle owned by Ivan that was found on his brother Wally's property. The analysis determined that this exact gun was used to shoot the eerily brand cartridges found at Area A. Concluding that both the Ruger and Deanshut's rifles belonging to Ivan Malat were discharged in Belangelo. With Ivan in custody for the attack on poor onions, police were given strict instructions not to mention a word to the press about the Belangelo murders.
弹道测试还使用了属于伊万并在其弟弟沃利房产中发现的安舒茨步枪进行。分析确定，正是这把枪被用来发射在A区发现的早期牌子弹。这得出结论：属于伊万·马拉特的鲁格和安舒茨步枪都在贝兰格洛被发射过。由于伊万因袭击保罗·奥尼尔斯而被拘留，警方接到严格指示，不得向媒体透露半点关于贝兰格洛谋杀案的消息。
In order to avoid any media attention jeopardizing their efforts in building their case. On May 29, just two days before Ivan's second scheduled court appearance, Superintendent Clive Small opened to the Sunday Herald newspaper to find a story which began. A lone investigation by a young detective has led police to believe the Belangelo Forest Backpacker murders could be linked to a rape case more than 20 years ago. The problematic article went on to detail the investigation into Ivan Malat for the backpacker murders but with many incorrect specifics. In particular, despite the large, dedicated team working under Superintendent Small, the
为了避免任何媒体关注危及其构建案件的努力。5月29日，即伊万第二次预定出庭日期的两天前，克莱夫·斯莫尔警司翻开《星期日先驱报》（Sunday Herald），看到了一篇以这样一句话开头的报道：“一名年轻侦探的独立调查让警方相信，贝兰格洛森林背包客谋杀案可能与20多年前的一起强奸案有关。”这篇有问题的文章接着详细描述了对伊万·马拉特因背包客谋杀案进行的调查，但有许多不正确的细节。特别是，尽管斯莫尔警司手下有一支庞大而敬业的团队，但
Sunday Herald article inaccurately credited Ivan's capture to the solitary work conducted by Detective Senior Constable Paul Gordon, a member of Task Force Air who had been investigating Ivan since he had been handed the file on the Malat brothers. Small was convinced it was Detective Paul Gordon who leaked the story to the press. After initially denying the accusation, Gordon eventually admitted he received a phone call from the journalist but claimed he simply verified some facts about his history within the police force. While he refused to comment about the Malat investigation, when the reporter suggested
《星期日先驱报》的文章却错误地将伊万的落网归功于高级警员保罗·戈登（Paul Gordon）一人进行的独家调查，保罗是空军特别工作组的成员，自接到马拉特兄弟的档案以来一直在调查伊万。斯莫尔确信是保罗·戈登警探将这个消息泄露给媒体的。在最初否认这一指控后，戈登最终承认他接到了记者的电话，但他声称自己只是核实了他在警察部队中历史的一些事实。当记者暗示他凭一己之力破获了此案时，他拒绝就马拉特调查发表评论，戈登回应道：“我只是运气好。”
he had single-handedly cracked the case, Gordon responded, I was just lucky. As outlined in his book Inside Australia's Biggest Manhunt, Superintendent Small had been wary about some of Gordon's investigative work prior to publication of the article, including the detective's initial failure to look beyond the computerised records of the Malat brothers' criminal backgrounds, something that Small considered a basic error. Small was also critical of Gordon's indiscreet and overzealous questioning of Ivan's workmates, which may have tipped their suspect to the fact he was being investigated for the Balangelo
正如斯莫尔警司在他的书《澳大利亚最大搜捕内幕》（Inside Australia's Biggest Manhunt）中所述，在文章发表之前，斯莫尔就对戈登的一些调查工作保持警惕，包括这位侦探最初未能超越马拉特兄弟犯罪背景的计算机化记录进行调查，斯莫尔认为这是一个基本错误。斯莫尔还批评了戈登对伊万同事的轻率和过分热心的盘问，这可能已经向他们的嫌疑人泄露了风声，让他知道自己正在因贝兰格洛谋杀案而受到调查。
killings. Small explained, I was furious. The article posed a significant risk to the investigation. Its account of Gordon's role was both completely untrue and a betrayal of the team effort behind the arrest, and it contravened my explicit instructions about not talking to the media. After all our efforts to convince the media that everyone would be treated equally and that no one would get the jump on their rivals, the Herald's story risked starting a free-for-all
斯莫尔解释道：“我当时气疯了。这篇文章给调查工作带来了重大风险。它对戈登角色的叙述完全不真实，背叛了逮捕背后的团队努力，并且违反了我关于不要与媒体交谈的明确指示。在我们为说服媒体每个人都会受到平等对待且没有人会超越竞争对手而做出种种努力之后，《先驱报》的故事有可能引发一场争夺独家新闻的自由混战。”由于泄密事件，高级警员保罗·戈登被移出了空军特别工作组。
scramble for scoops. As a result of the leak, Detective Scenicunstable Paul Gordon was removed from task force air. The publicity put the task force in an awkward position, and Small was convinced that gave them no choice but to charge Ivan Malat for all seven of the Balangelo murders when he appeared in court two days later. On May 31, 1994, a clean cut, smartly dressed Ivan Malat sat expressionless in the Campbelltown local court as senior crown prosecutor Ian Lloyd publicly disclosed for the first time the details of the violent crimes committed against the seven Balangelo victims.
这一公开曝光将特别工作组置于尴尬的境地，斯莫尔确信这让他们别无选择，只能在两天后出庭时指控伊万·马拉特犯下所有七起贝兰格洛谋杀案。1994年5月31日，一个外表干净利落、衣着考究的伊万·马拉特面无表情地坐在坎贝尔敦地方法院，高级皇家检察官伊恩·劳埃德（Ian Lloyd）首次公开披露了针对七名贝兰格洛受害者所实施的暴力犯罪的细节。
Lloyd proceeded to outline the evidence that had so far been gathered against Ivan before formally charging him with the murders of 19-year-olds James Gibson and Deborah Everest, 20-year-olds Simone Schmiddle and Anja Habschied, 21-year-olds Gabor Neugebauer and Caroline Clark, and 22-year-old Joanne Walters. Ivan's lawyer John Marsden told the gathering media that the allegations against his client were based on nothing more than circumstantial innuendos. My client denies the serious allegations that have been made against him in court today. I do not intend in any way to minimise the serious and horrific nature of the allegations
劳埃德接着概述了迄今为止收集到的针对伊万的证据，然后正式指控他犯有谋杀19岁的詹姆斯·吉布森（James Gibson）和黛博拉·埃弗雷特、20岁的西蒙妮·施密德尔和安娅·哈布希德（Anja Habschied）、21岁的加博尔·诺伊格鲍尔和卡洛琳·克拉克以及22岁的琼·瓦尔特斯的罪行。伊万的律师约翰·马斯登向聚集的媒体表示，针对他的当事人的指控不过是基于间接的影射。“我的当事人否认了今天在法庭上对他的严重指控。我不打算以任何方式淡化针对他的指控的严重性和可怕性质，然而，为了我的当事人的公平起见——他明确表示自己没有犯下这些指控，且尚未被证明有罪——媒体应该允许我的当事人接受公平审判。”
against him, however, in fairness to my client, who has stated quite categorically that he is not guilty of the allegations, and who has not been proved guilty, the media should allow my client a fair trial. News that Ivan had been charged for the Balangelo serial killings came as a shock to those who knew him, with many refusing to believe he could be responsible for such brutal crimes. Former employers and co-workers described the accused killer as a model worker who was reliable, honest and hard-working. A former next-door neighbour labelled him as the perfect neighbour who had always been
伊万被指控犯有贝兰格洛连环杀人案的消息对那些认识他的人来说是个震惊，许多人拒绝相信他会对如此残酷的罪行负责。前雇主和同事将这名被指控的杀手描述为一名可靠、诚实且工作努力的模范工人。一位前邻居称他为完美的邻居，他总是
friendly and courteous, offering to lend a hand by helping fix their cars or loaning his lawnmower. Alex Malat believed his younger brother was innocent, insisting there had been a miscarriage of justice. Quote, I know you might think that because he's my brother I would defend him, but I'll tell you right now that if I thought he was guilty I'd shoot the bastard. Ivan's girlfriend, Tralinda, also refused to accept the charges, saying, I think the
为人友好且有礼貌，主动提出帮忙修理汽车或借出自己的割草机。亚历克斯·米拉特相信自己的弟弟是无辜的，坚信这是一起冤假错案。他说：“我知道你可能会觉得因为他是我的弟弟我才会替他辩护，但我现在就告诉你，如果我认为他有罪，我就会一枪崩了这个混蛋。”伊万的女友特拉琳达也拒绝接受这些指控，并表示：“我认为
police are covering something up, I have no idea what. Ivan is a very calm person, not violent, and he doesn't lose his temper, and he's not a fool. I mean, if he were the person, he wouldn't leave incriminating stuff lying around. He would never strike a woman, let alone rape and murder. He has a great respect for women, this I know. Ivan is more likely to walk away than have an argument. Then there are those things that are hard to explain, the things you just know about
警方在掩盖某些事情，我完全不知道是什么。伊万是一个非常冷静的人，不暴力，不会发脾气，而且他也不傻。我的意思是，如果他是那个人，他不会把 incriminating（罪证）物品随处乱丢。他绝不会对女人动手，更不用说强奸和谋杀。他非常尊重女性，这一点我知道。伊万宁愿走开也不会与人争吵。然后还有那些很难解释的事情，那些你对一个人
a person. This is the worst crime imaginable. I'd rather be dead than be connected to someone who would commit this. A week after Ivan was charged, his image appeared on the cover of Celebrity News and Entertainment magazine, Who Weekly, accompanied by the headline, Backpacker Serial Killings, The Accused. The five-page article included an overview of the murders he was accused of committing, along with information about the Malat family. Recognizing the magazine story hindered Ivan's chance of receiving a fair trial, the New
心知肚明的事情。这是能想象到的最糟糕的罪行。我宁愿死，也不愿与犯下这种罪行的人扯上关系。在伊万被起诉一周后，他的照片登上了《名人新闻与娱乐》杂志《Who Weekly》的封面，标题是“背包客连环谋杀案：被告”。这篇五页的文章概述了他被控犯下的谋杀案，以及有关米拉特家族的信息。这篇杂志报道意识到了解到它会阻碍伊万获得公正审判的机会，新
South Wales Attorney General immediately charged Who Weekly's publisher, Time Inc., with contempt of court, winning a Supreme Court injunction preventing further sales of the magazine unless the photos of the accused were covered with irremovable stickers. The court found Who Weekly guilty, with the magazine receiving a $100,000 fine, and its editor receiving a $10,000 fine. Investigators and the prosecution had until Ivan Malat's committal hearing scheduled for the end of the year to produce enough evidence to argue that the murder case should proceed to trial.
南威尔士州总检察长立即指控《Who Weekly》的出版商时代公司犯有藐视法庭罪，并赢得了最高法院的禁令，禁止进一步销售该杂志，除非被告的照片被用无法撕下的贴纸覆盖。法院裁定《Who Weekly》罪名成立，该杂志被罚款10万美元，其编辑被罚款1万美元。调查人员和控方必须在年底前为伊万·米拉特的预审听证会准备足够证据，以论证这起谋杀案应当进入审判程序。
According to the book Sins of the Brother by Mark Whitaker and Les Kennedy, preliminary forensic testing of over 100 items of evidence seized by police from their various Malat properties, including tents, sleeping bags, clothing, rope, a green water bottle, a sharpening stone, blankets, sheets, and a sword, revealed possible traces of blood. But none of the items returned to match for human blood, except one, a one-and-a-half metre length of sash cord recovered from a pillowcase found in Ivan's garage. The blood stains were tested against DNA samples taken from the parents of all the Belangelo victims, using what's known as a reverse paternity test.
根据马克·惠特克（Mark Whitaker）和莱斯·肯尼迪（Les Kennedy）合著的《兄弟的罪孽》（Sins of the Brother）一书，警方从米拉特家族的各个房产中查获了100多件证据，包括帐篷、睡袋、衣物、绳索、一个绿色水壶、一块磨刀石、毯子、床单和一把剑，初步法医检测显示这些物品可能有血迹残留。但除了一件物品外，没有一件物品检测出人类血液的匹配结果——那是一根长一米半的饰带，从伊万车库里发现的一个枕套中找到。这些血迹与采集自所有贝朗格（Belangelo）受害者父母的DNA样本进行了对比，使用的是所谓的反向亲子鉴定测试。
Forensic examiners concluded that the blood on the sash cord was 792,000 times more likely to come from a child of Caroline Clark's parents than from any other parents in the general population. When the bodies of Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark were discovered, investigators found traces of bodily fluids they believed may have come from the pair's killer. Swabs were taken from the victim's remains and given to a forensic scientist who was new to the method of testing employed at the time. Given his inexperience, he produced different results at the conclusion of each analysis.
法医鉴定人员得出结论，饰带上的血迹来自卡罗琳·克拉克（Caroline Clark）父母的孩子的可能性，比来自普通人群中任何其他父母的可能性高出792,000倍。当乔安妮·沃尔特斯（Joanne Walters）和卡罗琳·克拉克的尸体被发现时，调查人员在其中发现了他们认为可能来自凶手的体液痕迹。从受害者的遗体中提取了拭子，并交给了一位对当时采用的检测方法尚不熟悉的法医科学家。由于他的经验不足，他在每次分析结束时都得出了不同的结果。
When revisited after Ivan's arrest, the DNA samples appeared to have been severely damaged by his use of chemicals and equipment, and unfortunately, more experienced forensic experts were unable to reverse the error. Therefore, the source of the foreign DNA could not be attributed to any individual. As part of the forensic examination process, the Green Water Bottle-founded Ivan's property believed to belong to Simone Schmidel was put under infrared lighting to determine for certain whether something had been scratched off its bottom. There, clear as day, was the German backpacker's nickname, Simi.
在伊万被捕后重新检查时，这些DNA样本似乎因他使用的化学品和设备而严重受损，不幸的是，更有经验的法医专家无法逆转这个错误。因此，外源DNA的来源无法归因于任何人。作为法医检验过程的一部分，在伊万房产处发现的、被认为属于西蒙娜·施米德尔（Simone Schmidel）的绿色水壶被置于红外光下，以确定其底部是否被刮擦过什么。在那里，这位德国背包客的昵称“西米”（Simi）清晰可见。
Given the personal items belonging to the deceased backpackers that had been discovered at properties belonging to various members of the Malat family, police were not discounting the theories previously put forward by criminal profilers that more than one perpetrator may have been involved in the crimes. However, they had yet to uncover any concrete evidence to suggest anyone other than Ivan was responsible. The publicity centered on Ivan prompted a close friend of his brother David to come forward to police to report a suspicious incident that allegedly occurred over the Easterlong
鉴于在米拉特家族各成员名下房产中发现了属于已故背包客的个人物品，警方并未排除此前犯罪侧写师提出的犯罪可能涉及多名作案人员的理论。然而，他们尚未发现任何具体证据表明除了伊万之外还有其他人负有责任。围绕伊万的宣传促使他弟弟戴维的一位好朋友主动向警方报案，报告了一起涉嫌发生在1992年复活节长
weekend in 1992, when Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark went missing. The witness, Philip Polglaze, claimed he was asleep on the couch at the Malat family property in Guildford when he was awoken by Ivan and Richard Malat, who both lived at the house at the time. The two brothers were allegedly carrying guns, a bloodstained knife, a machete, backpacks, and passports. Richard jokingly said the blood was human, before allegedly remarking, Ivan could cut your head off with one blow, I've seen him do it.
周末期间的可疑事件，当时乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克失踪了。这名证人菲利普·波尔格莱兹（Philip Polglaze）声称，当他睡在吉尔福德（Guildford）米拉特家族房产的沙发上时，被伊万和理查德·米拉特（Richard Malat）吵醒，两人当时都住在该房屋内。据称这两兄弟当时携带了枪支、一把带血的刀、一把大砍刀、背包和护照。理查德开玩笑说血是人血，随后据称评论道：“伊万一击就能砍下你的头，我见他做过。”
Ivan allegedly responded, Richard can't stab anyone, he has to shoot them. Philip told authorities that during the time period the seven Balangelo murders occurred, David Malat told him that his family was worried Ivan was up to his old tricks. When Philip asked if this meant robbery, David allegedly responded, no, worse, and we think he's taking a brother with him. As detailed in the book Sins of the Brother by Les Kennedy and Mark Whitaker, Philip Polglaze's allegations prompted a judge to give approval for a covert listening device to be installed inside Richard Malat's caravan at hilltop.
伊万据称回应道：“理查德谁也刺不了，他只能开枪。”菲利普告诉当局，在发生七起贝朗格谋杀案的期间，戴维·米拉特曾对他说，他的家人担心伊万又在搞他的老把戏了。当菲利普问这是否意味着抢劫时，戴维据称回答说：“不，更糟糕，而且我们觉得他还带了一个兄弟。”正如莱斯·肯尼迪和马克·惠特克合著的《兄弟的罪孽》一书中所详细描述的那样，菲利普·波尔格莱兹的指控促使法官批准在位于山顶（Hilltop）的理查德·米拉特的房车内安装隐蔽窃听设备。
David's behaviour indicated he may have already suspected he was under police surveillance, only meeting with friends outdoors and making phone calls from public pay phones. Consequently, the device failed to capture anything of interest. During subsequent police interviews, Philip Polglaze's statements changed significantly, as he suffered from short-term memory loss as a result of a previous car accident. In an attempt to verify if there was any validity to his claims, police obtained a warrant that allowed them to covertly record a conversation between Philip and Richard. A meeting was arranged for the pair at the Crossroads Hotel in Kassoula.
戴维的行为表明他可能已经怀疑自己受到了警方监视，只在户外与朋友会面，并从公共公用电话打电话。因此，该设备未能捕捉到任何有价值的信息。在随后的警方讯问中，菲利普·波尔格莱兹的供词发生了重大变化，因为他此前因车祸导致短期记忆丧失。为了核实他的说法是否有根据，警方获得了一张搜查令，允许他们秘密录制菲利普和理查德之间的对话。两人被安排在卡苏拉（Kassoula）的十字路口酒店（Crossroads Hotel）会面。
Police officers were on standby in a van parked outside the premises, where they listened in on the recording. Little of the conversation between Philip and Richard made sense, as the latter appeared to be under the influence of alcohol. During their meeting, Philip brought up the night where Ivan allegedly returned to the Guilford home with a bloody knife, but Richard told him to keep his mouth shut about that. Philip voiced concerns that he could be considered an accessory after the fact, but Richard reassured that there was nothing to worry about, as police would arrest him before they ever went
警官们在停在 premises 外面的货车里待命，聆听录音。菲利普和理查德之间的对话几乎没什么逻辑，因为后者似乎受到了酒精的影响。在他们会面期间，菲利普提到了伊万据称带着一把血淋淋的刀回到吉尔福德家中的那个晚上，但理查德叫他闭紧嘴巴，不要谈论此事。菲利普表达了担心，认为自己可能会被视为事后从犯，但理查德安慰说没什么好担心的，因为警察在找菲利普之前就会先逮捕他。
after Philip. Philip asked what he should say to the police if he was questioned about the passports and the backpacks Ivan allegedly showed him that night, to which Richard responded, Just say nothing. Just tell them I've seen nothing. Absolutely nothing. You ask, are you arresting me, officer? And when he says no, just tell him to fuck off.
菲利普问，如果被盘问关于伊万那天晚上给他看过的护照和背包的事，他应该对警察说什么，对此理查德回答说：“什么都别说。就告诉他们我什么都没看到。绝对什么都没看到。你问，‘长官，你在逮捕我吗？’当他说没有时，就让他滚蛋。”
In regards to the camping gear belonging to Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark, police seized from his property, Richard explained he had obtained the equipment from, quote, all over the place, and had stolen some of the items whilst in the city. He then rambled about serial killers not stopping unless they get caught, quote. Where are we going to stop? Only when we get caught. You're not going to stop two years before. We're not going to stop because we think the police will be hot on our tail.
关于属于乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克的露营装备，警方从他的房产中查获了这些东西，理查德解释说他是从“四面八方”弄来的，并且在城里时偷了一些物品。然后他喋喋不休地谈论连环杀手如果不被抓是不会罢休的，并引用道：“我们要去哪里停下来？只有当我们被抓到时。你不会在两年前就停下来的。我们不会因为觉得警察紧追不舍就停下来。”
Once you get that sort of fucking ding in your, I figure it's just like having a beer. When are you going to stop? When the pub closes? Or do we buy takeaway to take home in case we're thirsty? When Richard remarked that Philip was asking the same questions as police, the informer sensed his cover was at risk of being blown. To seem less conspicuous, Philip quickly remarked, fuck me dead, maybe I should have been a fucking copper.
“一旦你的脑子里有了那种该死的印记，我觉得这就像喝一杯啤酒。你什么时候停下来？当酒吧关门的时候？还是我们买外卖带回家以防口渴？”当理查德评论说菲利普问的问题和警察一样时，告密者感觉到他的伪装有被识破的危险。为了显得不那么显眼，菲利普赶紧说：“真见鬼，也许我他妈应该当个警察。”
As the conversation dragged on, Philip mentioned his disbelief that one person could be responsible for all the Belangelo killings, to which Richard replied, that's what we're worried about. One of these fucking big German cunts is supposed to be about six foot four and 18, 19 stone. Here he is with a broken jaw, broken arm, broken fucking back. What? One bloke do all this to him. And if you can do that to him, how come some skinny fucking Pommie backpacker get away
随着对话的拖延，菲利普提到他不相信一个人能对所有的贝朗格谋杀案负责，对此理查德回答说：“这正是我们所担心的。这些他妈的德国大块头据说有六英尺四英寸高，18、19英石重。他就在这里，下巴骨折、手臂骨折、他妈的脊椎骨折。什么？一个人对这一切负全责。既然你能对他做这些，那怎么会让一个瘦弱的 Pommie（英国人）背包客从他手中逃脱呢？”
from him? This comment immediately stood out to the police officers listening in on the discussion, as Paul Anion's physical stature and to the full extent of Gabor Neugebauer's injuries had not yet been released to the public. Richard's remarks were compelling, but were not enough to warrant his arrest, and the undercover sting came to an unsatisfying conclusion. Following the failed sting, Richard Millat told France he was convinced Philip Poglase was working with the police, an assertion that compelled the informer to go into hiding.
这条评论立刻引起了正在监听讨论的警官们的注意，因为保罗·安尼翁（Paul Anion）的体型以及加博尔·诺伊格鲍尔（Gabor Neugebauer）受伤的全部程度当时尚未向公众公布。理查德的言论很有说服力，但不足以成为逮捕他的理由，卧底行动以令人不满意的结局告终。在卧底行动失败后，理查德·米拉特告诉朋友，他确信菲利普·波尔格莱兹在与警方合作，这一断言迫使这位告密者隐蔽起来。
Then, just before Philip could testify at Ivan Millat's committal hearing, he was involved in a fatal car accident that claimed his life. When Richard heard the somber news, he offered no sympathy. On June 28, a visibly agitated Ivan reappeared in the Campbelltown local court, where he surprised those in attendance by sacking his long-standing lawyer John Marsden, the man who had helped him evade serious rape and armed robbery charges in the 70s. Marsden believed the decision was based on him encouraging Ivan to plead guilty to the bilingual murders on the grounds of insanity, allowing them to argue for diminished responsibility.
然后，就在菲利普准备在伊万·米拉特的预审听证会上作证之前，他遭遇了一场致命的车祸，失去了生命。当理查德听到这个阴郁的消息时，他没有表示任何同情。6月28日，情绪明显激动的伊万再次出现在坎贝尔敦（Campbelltown）地方法院，他在那里解雇了他长期以来的律师约翰·马森（John Marsden），此举让在场的人感到惊讶，正是这个人曾帮助他在70年代逃脱了严重的强奸和持械抢劫指控。马森认为，这一决定是基于他曾鼓励伊万以精神失常为由对贝朗格谋杀案认罪，从而允许他们辩称责任减轻。
Other members of the Millat family stated his dismissal was due to Ivan's strong belief that Marsden was in cahoots with the police. Despite the magistrate's request that he reconsider this decision, Ivan declared he would be representing himself that day instead. He criticized the media for the way they were covering the case and continued to declare his innocence, arguing that he was being framed and the police were, quote, making it up as they go along. Many high-profile barristers came forward willing to take Marsden's place and represent
米拉特家族的其他成员表示，解雇他是因为伊万坚信马森与警方勾结。尽管地方法官请求他重新考虑这一决定，但伊万宣布他当天将亲自出庭辩护。他批评媒体报道此案的方式，并继续宣称自己无辜，辩称自己是被陷害的，警察是“边走边编”。许多知名大律师纷纷表示愿意取代马森并代表
Ivan, wanting to take advantage of the immense exposure in what was set to become one of the most high-profile and publicized criminal trials in Australian legal history. The Millats felt lawyers from New South Wales may be too close to the police and therefore deemed them untrustworthy, leading Ivan to hire Queensland-based solicitor Andrew Bow. Ivan appeared with his new solicitor at Campbelltown local court on July 5, where he was reminded in custody until his next court appearance. Meanwhile, his ex-wife Karen was placed in witness protection amidst concerns for her safety.
伊万，希望利用这起注定成为澳大利亚法律史上备受瞩目和宣传的刑事审判之一的巨大曝光率。米拉特家族觉得新南威尔士州的律师可能与警察走得太近，因此认为他们不可信，这导致伊万聘请了总部位于昆士兰州的诉讼律师安德鲁·鲍（Andrew Bow）。7月5日，伊万与他的新律师一同出现在坎贝尔敦地方法院，并在那里被还押候审，直至下次出庭。与此同时，他的前妻凯伦（Karen）出于对其安全的担忧而被置于证人保护之下。
John Marsden continued to represent other members of the Millat family, including Richard and Wally Millat. On August 20, the pair appeared at Campbelltown local court under Marsden's representation to face charges against them. Richard pled guilty to possession of five prohibited weapons, unlawful possession of a driver's license, and possession of cannabis. Wally pled guilty to illegal possession of firearms, cultivating two cannabis plants, and possession of cannabis.
约翰·马森继续代表米拉特家族的其他成员，包括理查德和沃利·米拉特（Wally Millat）。8月20日，两人在马森的代表下出现在坎贝尔敦地方法院，面临对他们的指控。理查德对非法持有五种违禁武器、非法持有驾照以及持有大麻的罪名表示认罪。沃利对非法持有枪支、种植两株大麻植物以及持有大麻的罪名表示认罪。
Both men were sentenced to a good behaviour bond and issued with a monetary fine, plus court costs. On October 24, 1994, five months after his arrest, Ivan Millat's committal hearing commenced at Campbelltown local court to determine whether there was enough evidence for the backpacker murder case to proceed to trial. Ivan maintained a relaxed and calm demeanour as Crown Prosecutor Ian Lloyd outlined the case against him, but his opening arguments were cut short when the court was forced to evacuate due to a bomb threat, which was later determined to be a hoax.
这两名男子均被判处守行令，并被处以罚款外加诉讼费。1994年10月24日，在他被捕五个月后，伊万·米拉特的预审听证会在坎贝尔敦地方法院开始，以确定是否有足够的证据将背包客谋杀案交付审判。当皇家检察官伊恩·劳埃德（Ian Lloyd）陈述针对他的案件时，伊万保持着轻松平静的举止，但他的开场陈述在中途被打断，因为法院因炸弹威胁被迫疏散，该威胁后来被证实是虚假的。
As the committal hearing continued, a full summary of all the available evidence implicating Ivan Millat was detailed. When the backpack belonging to Simone Schmiddle was presented with the initials I am written on the inside flap, Ivan yelled from across the room, accusing the police of writing the initials themselves. This assertion was contradicted when Ivan's sister-in-law Joan testified that the initials were already on the backpack when he gave it to her in late 1992. Over 200 witnesses were called before the court, including Steve Wright, the British
随着预审听证会的继续，涉及伊万·米拉特的全部可用证据的完整摘要得到了详细说明。当属于西蒙娜·施米德尔的背包被出示，上面写着内盖上的“I.M.”首字母缩写时，伊万在房间另一头大喊，指责警方自己伪造了这些首字母。当伊万的嫂子琼（Joan）作证说，当伊万在1992年底把背包给她时，上面就已经有这些首字母缩写时，这一断言不攻自破。法院传唤了200多名证人，其中包括史蒂夫·赖特（Steve Wright），这位英国
backpacker who swapped tents with Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark. Other former travel companions and family members of the deceased backpackers were also called. They were able to formally identify the items recovered from the Millat properties as those belonging to their loved ones. Englishman Paul Unions made an appearance to provide details about his attempted kidnapping. At the time, he was only referred to as Witness A due to a suppression order granted to protect his identity. Ivan's ex-wife Karen also took the stand, describing her former husband as a strong
这名背包客曾与乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克交换过帐篷。其他几位前同行旅伴以及死者家属也出庭作证。他们能够正式辨认出从米拉特财产中找回的物品属于他们深爱的亲人。英国人保罗·尤宁斯出庭提供有关他遭绑架未遂的细节。当时，由于法院批准了保护其身份的压制令，他仅被称为“证人A”。伊万的前妻卡伦也出庭作证，她将前夫描述为一个身材强壮的
man who lifted weights every night of the week. She testified that Ivan took her to Belanglo State Forest numerous times over the course of their 12-year relationship, and that during one visit, he shot a kangaroo before proceeding to kick it and slit its throat. Prior to their divorce being finalised in 1989, Karen said the only camping equipment Ivan owned was an orange and green tent. Karen confirmed Ivan owned several firearms, including a rifle and a revolver. Quote,
男子，一周七天每晚都进行举重锻炼。她作证说，在他们长达12年的关系中，伊万曾多次带她去贝朗洛州立森林，而在其中一次访问中，他射杀了一只袋鼠，随后对它踢打并割断了喉咙。在1989年他们的离婚最终敲定之前，卡伦称伊万拥有的唯一露营装备是一个橙绿色帐篷。卡伦证实伊万拥有多支枪械，包括一支步枪和一支左轮手枪。引述：
Ivan was gun crazy with his firearms. He would shoot at anything he could find. There was a target on a tree, cans, anything he could see. When shown the pistol that was found under Ivan's washing machine, Karen confirmed it belonged to her ex-husband, and that he kept it wrapped in a sock under the front seat of his car, loaded at all times. In Ivan's defence, his legal team presented reported sightings of some of the backpackers after the dates they were allegedly last seen alive.
“伊万对枪支极其疯狂。他会向他能找到的任何东西射击。树上有个靶子，罐头，任何他能看到的东西。”当被出示在伊万洗衣机下发现的手枪时，卡伦确认它属于她的前夫，并且他一直将其用袜子包裹着放在汽车前排座椅下方，随时处于上膛状态。在伊万的辩护中，其法律团队提出了在背包客据称最后一次被活捉的日期之后的一些目击报告。
In one sighting, a witness claimed to have picked up two British backpackers named Joe and Caroline on the southern outskirts of Sydney between April 21 and April 23, 1992. This was five days after Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark departed Sydney to Hitchhike along the Hume Highway, a time frame in which Ivan Malap was confirmed to have been at work. However, the prosecution had already disproven all reported sightings of the seven backpackers beyond their disappearance dates, and the Defence Council declined the magistrate's offer to call any witnesses to the stand to try and prove otherwise. The defence also attempted to cast doubt over whether Ivan was the Malap brother responsible
在一桩目击报告中，一名证人声称在1992年4月21日至4月23日期间，在悉尼南部郊区搭载了两名分别名叫乔和卡罗琳的英国背包客。这发生在乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克离开悉尼沿休姆公路搭便车五天后，而这段时间正是伊万·马拉特被证实上班的时间。然而，控方已经驳回了所有关于七名背包客在失踪日期之后被目击的报告，辩护律师也拒绝了地方法官传唤任何证人出庭试图证明相反情况的提议。辩护方还试图让人怀疑伊万是否是应该对此类犯罪负责的马拉特兄弟之一。
for the crimes. They highlighted that Richard Malat also fit the description of Paul Anion's attacker in 1990, as he sported a distinct Murphy-style mustache at the time. Alluding to the cigarette butts found at Joanne Walters and Caroline Clark's crime scene, Richard was a heavy smoker, unlike Ivan, who had quit the habit 11 years prior in 1981. Richard Malat was put on the stand and questioned about the tent, sleeping bag and hairbrush found on his property that had belonged to Joanne and Caroline, but he denied knowing anything about the items or how they came to be in his possession.
他们强调理查德·马拉特也符合1990年保罗·安尼恩袭击者的体貌特征，因为他当时留着标志性的墨菲式小胡子。暗示在乔安妮·沃尔特斯和卡罗琳·克拉克案发现场发现的烟头时，理查德是个老烟枪，这与在11年前的1981年就已戒烟的伊万不同。理查德·马拉特被传唤出庭，并被盘问关于在他财产上发现的属于乔安妮和卡罗琳的帐篷、睡袋和发刷，但他否认知道这些物品的任何信息，也否认它们是如何落入他手中的。
Superintendent Clive Small was the final witness to take the stand at the committal hearing. He emphasised that Ivan not only fit the physical description and personal background of Paul Anion's attacker, but also drove the same vehicle used by the assailant. Under cross-examination from Ivan's defence team, the superintendent agreed that other members of the Malat family also fit the perpetrator's description to varying degrees, but concluded, I don't believe any other member owned a silver four-wheel drive with a white top and a red stripe down the side. Seven weeks after it began, the committal hearing came to an end on December 12th,
克莱夫·斯莫尔总督察是预审听证会上最后一位出庭的证人。他强调，伊万不仅在体貌特征和个人背景上符合保罗·安尼恩袭击者的特征，而且驾驶的也是袭击者所使用的同款车辆。在伊万辩护团队的盘问下，总督察同意马拉特家族的其他成员在不同程度上也符合凶手的描述，但他总结道：“我不认为其他任何成员拥有一辆银色、白顶、侧面带有红条纹的四轮驱动汽车。”在预审听证会开始七周后，它于12月12日告一段落，
with the court satisfied enough evidence was presented for Ivan Malat to stand trial for the seven Belangalo murders. The trial was set to commence in the New South Wales Supreme Court the following year. The alleged killer showed no emotion as he was let out of the courtroom. His lawyer Andrew Bowe fronted the media to express concern that the extensive coverage of the committal hearing would make it difficult for his client to receive a fair trial, as it would be near impossible to find an impartial jury. Andrew Bowe, quote, I think this case will be a test for how this community and the criminal justice system in Australia deals with such a public hearing of allegations at committal.
法院对是否有足够证据让伊万·马拉特因七起贝朗洛谋杀案接受审判表示满意。审判原定于次年在新南威尔士州最高法院开庭。这位所谓的凶手被带出法庭时没有表现出任何情绪。他的律师安德鲁·鲍伊面对媒体表达了担忧，认为对预审听证会的广泛报道将使他的客户很难得到公正的审判，因为几乎不可能找到一个公正的陪审团。安德鲁·鲍伊说：“我认为这个案子将考验这个社区以及澳大利亚的刑事司法系统如何处理在预审中如此公开的指控听证会。”
Prior to Ivan Malat's trial, renovations were undertaken at the New South Wales Supreme Court building to ensure the amenities were more accommodating for the prospective jurors during proceedings, which were expected to last upwards of six months. The walkway between the cells and the courthouse would also be covered to prevent camera crews from capturing the daily journey of the accused. The trial was initially scheduled to begin on June 26, 1995, but disputes amongst Ivan's legal team regarding finances delayed the commencement date. Given the trial was expected to run for a considerable length of time and deal with complex legal issues, Ivan's legal team felt the fees being offered to them by legal aid were insufficient.
在伊万·马拉特受审之前，新南威尔士州最高法院大楼进行了翻修，以确保在预计长达六个月以上的诉讼过程中，配套设施对未来的陪审员更具包容性。看守所与法院之间的步行道也将加盖顶棚，以防止摄像机拍摄到被告的日常行程。审判最初计划于1995年6月26日开始，但伊万法律团队内部在资金问题上的争执推迟了开庭日期。鉴于审判预计将持续相当长的时间并处理复杂的法律问题，伊万的法律团队认为法律援助提供给他们的费用是不够的。
Ivan refused to work with any other solicitors, demanding legal aid pay his team an above-average rate. The commission refused, determining they would only pay the initial base rate and Ivan would have to cover any additional costs at his own expense. After a lengthy appeals process which delayed the trial for nine months, three appellate judges unanimously deemed Ivan's request to be unacceptable, effectively leaving the defendant with no legal representation unless he was willing to contribute the difference in cost. With no other avenue of appeal, Ivan's legal team eventually accepted the initial lower offer, with the trial scheduled to commence in March, 1996. Speculation continued to run rife as to whether Ivan Malat acted alone. Prior to his capture,
伊万拒绝与任何其他律师合作，要求法律援助向他的团队支付高于平均水平的费用。委员会予以拒绝，并决定他们只支付初始基本费率，伊万必须自掏腰包承担任何额外费用。经过长达九个月的漫长上诉程序推迟了审判后，三位上诉法官一致认为伊万的要求不可接受，这实际上让被告在没有法律代表的情况下，除非他愿意自己掏钱支付差价。在没有其他上诉途径的情况下，伊万的法律团队最终接受了最初的较低报价，审判计划于1996年3月开始。关于伊万·马拉特是否单独作案的猜测继续甚嚣尘上。在他被捕之前，
various criminal profilers had indicated their belief that the killer had an accomplice, with several theorizing the crimes may have been committed by brothers. FBI agents and some task force air investigators were less convinced. Based on the fact Paul Unions was targeted by a single perpetrator and that known serial killers rarely deviate from their established demo, they were certain that Ivan acted alone. Dr Peter Bradhurst, the forensic pathologist from the New South Wales Institute of Forensic Medicine, who had conducted the post mordems of all seven Belangelo victims, joined the group of people to suggest two killers may be involved. During the final days of Ivan Malat's committal hearing, Dr Bradhurst testified in
各路犯罪侧写师曾表示坚信凶手有同伙，其中几人推测这些罪行可能是由兄弟俩犯下的。联邦调查局特工和一些专案组侦探则没那么确信。基于保罗·尤宁斯是单人作案的目标且已知的连环杀手很少偏离其既定作案手法的确凿事实，他们确信伊万是单人作案。新南威尔士州法医学研究所的法医病理学家彼得·布拉德赫斯特博士曾对所有七名贝朗洛受害者进行过尸检，他也加入了认为可能涉及两名凶手的人群中。在伊万·马拉特预审听证会的最后几天，布拉德赫斯特博士在法庭上
court that for one person to be responsible for all seven murders, the killer would have had to incapacitate one of the victims before dealing with the other. When asked whether his forensic expertise could determine whether more than one killer was involved, Dr Bradhurst responded. With each of the pairs of backpackers that were killed, there appears to be two different patterns of injury. With Caroline Clark and Joanne Walters, Caroline Clark had predominant injuries of gunshot wounds to the head and only one stab wound being apparent. With Joanne Walters, she had multiple stab wounds. Similarly, with Gabor Neugebauer and Anja Habschied, Gabor Neugebauer had gunshot wounds to the head, evidence of strangulation and gagging, whereas Anja Habschied had been decapitated.
作证说，要让一个人对所有七起谋杀案负责，凶手必须在处理另一个受害者之前先使其中一个受害者失去抵抗能力。当被问及他的法医专业知识能否确定是否涉及多名凶手时，布拉德赫斯特博士回答说：“在被杀害的每对背包客中，似乎存在两种不同的受伤模式。对于卡罗琳·克拉克和乔安妮·沃尔特斯，卡罗琳·克拉克的主要伤势是头部枪伤，且明显只有一处刺伤。至于乔安妮·沃尔特斯，她有多处刺伤。同样，对于加博尔·诺伊格鲍尔和安娅·哈布希德，加博尔·诺伊格鲍尔有头部枪伤、勒死和堵嘴的痕迹，而安娅·哈布希德则被斩首。”
Further, with James Gibson and Deborah Everest, there were two different patterns of injuries. I would attempt to think it more likely that more than one person was involved. To be concluded next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，对于詹姆斯·吉布森和黛博拉·埃弗雷特，也有两种不同的受伤模式。我认为涉及多人的可能性更大。下周继续。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。